إن موجة الحر القاسية التي تعرضت لها إيطاليا ودول
جنوب أوروبا الأخرى
ستزداد سوءًا،
فنحن نسمع أن اليوم هو في الواقع
أروع يوم من الأيام الخمسة المقبلة،
وسيصبح أكثر سخونة في نهاية هذا الأسبوع وحتى
أكثر سخونة في الأسبوع المقبل الآن السلطات لديها
أصدرت تنبيهات صحية تحذر الناس،
وخاصة الأشخاص الضعفاء، من البقاء في
الداخل وعدم الإفراط في تناول الطعام والبقاء رطبًا
واستخدام المياه لمحاولة التبريد هنا في
روما والمدن السياحية الأخرى في إيطاليا.
وتبذل السلطات كل ما في
وسعها لمحاولة إبقاء الناس مرتاحين.
قالوا للناس إنهم يجب أن يحاولوا
الذهاب إلى المتاحف خلال الجزء الأكثر سخونة
من اليوم، فهم يوفرون المياه مجانًا
ويحذرون الناس من محاولة
عدم البقاء معرضين للحرارة ولكن بالنسبة
للعديد من الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى مدينة سياحية
في  إيطاليا هي فرصة العمر مرة واحدة وهم
يكسرون هذه
الحرارة بغض النظر عن باربي اللاتينية على قناة سي إن إن
روما